[Music]
thank you so according to the schedule I
have three minutes to follow image and
talk about logic
algorithms AI
and
uh and how all that related to Industry
day um yeah so let's um yeah so I thank
my co-organizers uh you know G and Dan
and suip Virginia for giving me this
opportunity um all right uh so the main
goal of the program uh is basically to
bring together researchers from uh these
very disjoint communities and I would
like to spend maybe a minute on uh
explaining how they all connected to
each other uh and how that might be uh
applicable to IND uh so the the the
setup is extremely simple uh in many
cases uh we have a database query into
the database and we're supposed to
answer I talk to the algorithms people
the first thing they ask is what is a
database database is a graph yes so now
we are you know in uh speaking
terms uh I lied a little bit you know a
database is actually a collection of
hypergraphs but you know talking about
the same the same language and then the
the the next you know the natural
question is um uh you know how best to
answer a query that is issued to to the
database and then you now have to break
this question up you know what is a
query what is best right and uh so
that's um where logic comes into the
picture because logic iic is a very very
powerful and expressive query language
so now you can uh kind of break this
problem down and you will know precisely
what you're talking about you know
Computing the triangles in a graph
that's just a
conjuncted right and algorithms uh
conferences papers about triangles and
clicks and things like that uh apsp
shortest part that's a precursive query
and so on and so as you expand this
language using logic and um you know
algebraic extensions you um you'll be
able to kind of break this problem down
and then from a database point of view
typically we have uh statistics on the
database so this is I want to make a
connection to the other program on
streaming and sketching and sampling
those are Bas very fundamental
techniques uh in databases to to answer
the qu and the framework for analyzing
this is you know you can see all of
these keywords find R complexity fix
parameter so that's basically the
question question of of best you know
how do you break down what is best um
there could be updates to the database
and how do you answer the quer
efficiently given that you have already
answered the previous version of the
query and datat Bas is known as
incremental view maintenance in
algorithms such a dynamic algorithms so
that's how all of these things are
connected together and we have a variety
of activities we have four workshops uh
three of which have already been done
and there's one coming up
in logic and algebra inquiry evaluation
uh next week we after um and many other
activities you can view them from our
website uh including music nights game
nights and running and so please come
join us around um and finally I think my
three minutes up uh you know i' to thank
the Simons and all of the supporting
stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
all right continuing in our lightning
talks uh we'll have